bonjour David Lisnard bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes Le
Maire les républicains de Cannes
candidats donc à la présidence de cette
Association des Maires de France et
comme Philippe Laurent est enceinte
pendant un petit peu plus de 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale et
toujours à mes côtés Stéphane Vernet qui
dirige le bureau parisien de westfrance
on commence par deux petites questions
d'actualité davidisner d'abord qui
touche votre ville de Cannes puisqu'on
s'en souvient la semaine dernière et une
attaque dans votre ville de Cannes
devant le commissariat un homme qui a
agressé des policiers est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez plus
d'informations en est l'enquête moi j'ai
les informations qui ont été divulguées
dans la presse et qui sont du ressort
d'ailleurs du parquet c'est pas un maire
de divulguier le contenu d'une
information judiciaire c'est une
mauvaise habitude qui a été prise en
France que chacun divulgue ce qui relève
du judiciaire on a un individu qui au
nom du Prophète a proféré des coups de
couteau en essayant de tuer deux
policiers et les autres policiers on
neutralisés l'enquête pour l'instant
laisserait apparaître qu'il n'y aurait
pas de lien avec une filière terroriste
voilà je mais ça renvoie cette réalité
que l'on vit je l'ai souvent évoqué je
suis des années des années ville de
Cannes est une ville contrastée comme
beaucoup de nos villes c'est une ville
les plus contrastées de France avec un
taux de pauvreté élevé puisqu'on a plus
de 20% là où la moyenne française est de
13,8 et une ville qui est aussi au
carrefour de flux migratoires et donc
des tensions qu'on rencontre dans toute
la société française aujourd'hui on va
parler de la crise sanitaire puisque les
mers sont en première ligne face à cette
crise sanitaire on le voit les taux
d'incidence remonte vous avez été vous
l'un des premiers alerter sur cette
question se souvient de l'opposition du
gouvernement face à votre volonté
d'élargir la vaccination dans votre
ville à vous opposer à la prolongation
du port du masque en extérieur comment
vous qualifier aujourd'hui la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
et est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les leçons ont été tirées que les mers
sont plus écoutées aujourd'hui
certaines leçons ont été tirées
évidemment
moi j'ai un principe de base dans la vie
c'est c'est que les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les lois nécessaires c'est
pas c'est de Montesquieu et notamment
lorsqu'il y a une crise et j'ai vécu
malheureusement des inondations
meurtrières à plusieurs reprises il peut
être très très précis sur l'information
et être cohérent
ce qui est inutile par exemple c'est
lorsque deux choses effectivement le
port du masque en extérieur ça peut
paraître accessoire mais c'est le cas de
le dire d'ailleurs mais le fait alors
que l'on sait que ça ne sert à rien sauf
s'il y a une densité stagnante dans un
marché par exemple moi je l'ai rendu
obligatoire là les marchés alimentaires
etc ça ça démotive le citoyen et ça crée
de finalement ça tue un peu liens
civique et c'est une un travers très
français très tatillon très
bureaucratique de multiplier les normes
que de multiplier les règles mais de ne
pas faire appliquer les règles
nécessaires ensuite deuxièmement je
pense que la messe du du mardi soir avec
le président de la République qui au
dernier annonce ce que découvre les
préfets les mers et parfois les
ministres à la télé autant on peut la
comprendre dans un premier temps
lorsqu'il fallait dramatiser pour
montrer la gravité du virus de cette
inconnue d'ailleurs à l'époque en termes
de l'État et de contagiosité jusqu'au
jusqu'à l'été 2020 il y avait encore des
incertitudes aujourd'hui à mon avis elle
participe de cette là aussi de cette
infantilisation de la vie publique et
qui en plus je pense est négatif pour
l'exécutif parce que ça lui fait reposer
sur les épaules une responsabilité qui
devrait être partagée y compris au plan
local c'était la neuvième adresse du
président de la République aux Français
sur le thème de la crise sanitaire c'est
la locution de trop pour vous non je
vais pas dire que c'est à chacun de se
faire son opinion il est légitime il est
pourriant de la République mais annoncer
une prise de parole en raison d'une
dramatique sanitaire et puis en réalité
proféré un propos qui
comme préoccupation peut-être autre
chose que la crise sanitaire mais les
prochaines élections présidentielles et
législatives à mon sens était un acte
plus politicien qu'autre chose sur la
décision la décision de conditionner le
la troisième dose au bénéfice du Pass
sanitaire ça c'était une bonne décision
ou pas
je crois pas que ce soit une bonne
décision je serai efficace pourtant le
passé
ses preuves dans tous les pays qui l'ont
adopté et la vaccination est absolument
nécessaire j'en suis un ardent promoteur
depuis longtemps on va parler en
revanche vous savez il y a l'acceptation
civique et ça ça passe par l'explication
la pédagogie et pas par les 100 ans
c'est le côté un peu infantilisant qui à
mon avis produit un effet inverse on va
parler de votre candidature à la tête de
cette association
parce que c'est c'est dans la continuité
de d'un choix de vie j'ai commencé à
m'engager dans la vie publique depuis
très longtemps quand j'étais gamin bien
que personne ne faisait politique chez
moi j'ai pas du tout issu de cet univers
là je me suis donné d'indépendants et de
commerçant ancien sportif qui se sont
recyclés dans le petit commerce mais
j'ai toujours été engagé j'ai toujours
aimé ça et j'ai eu une première
expérience professionnelle et Jacques
Pélissard c'était il y a plus de 20 ans
et j'ai eu la chance de commencer avec
Mélissa qui était député maire de
Lons-le-Saunier j'ai accompagné dans le
Jura dans les 5 47 communes de sa
circonscription dans sa commune et il
était vice-président de la MF comme moi
je suis depuis quelques années et il
était motivé par l'Association des
maires de France et c'est lui je pense
qu'il m'a donné cette vocation là et
ensuite lorsque je suis devenu élu local
en 2001 je ne sais pas encore mère mais
j'ai représenté ma commune de Cannes à
l'Association des maires de France
depuis 2001 j'ai été auprès de Jack
Mélissa alors ce qui était président de
l'AMF président de service public 2000
qui était le beau cabinet d'audit que
l'on a réor restructuré renforcer qui
est devenu espélia parce que j'ai fait
aussi un peu d'audit dans ma vie et
lorsque je suis devenu mère en 2014 je
me suis engagé ardemment à la MF et
aujourd'hui François barman apporte sa
confiance et j'en suis honoré qu'est-ce
qui vous différencie fondamentalement de
Philippe Laurent moi je sais pas c'est à
vous de le dire c'est au merde le dire
non mais non parce que moi je je cherche
pas à me différencier je cherche à être
cohérent à apporter un projet qui est le
mien
ce qu'on va faire de l'association c'est
la manière dont je souhaite
effectivement que l'Association des
maires de France bien sûr soit dynamisée
parce qu'il faut toujours profiter du
renouvellement des instances pour
apporter un souffle nouveau mais soit
conforme à sa vocation qui est inscrite
dans son objet même c'est dans l'objet
de la MF que d'être pluraliste que
d'être représentative et j'ai essayé
d'être fidèle à cette tradition c'est
plus qu'une tradition c'est ce qui fait
la singularité la crédibilité la force
de la MF c'est d'être représentatif des
mairies de France donc dans mon équipe
il y a un équilibre entre la ruralité et
je suis patient dit l'urbanité mais les
communes plus grandes il y a bien sûr
beaucoup de mères qui ne sont pas
encartés parce que beaucoup de merde
n'ont pas de d'engagement partisans mais
parmi ceux qui sont qui ont un
engagement partisan on respecte le
spectre des partis politiques y compris
de l'ude d'ailleurs qui puisque j'ai
plusieurs idées dans mes équipes et
c'est ce qui fait c'est la garantie dans
la durée de la capacité d'indépendance
de l'AMF et surtout de sa capacité de
porter une parole libre à l'égard de
l'exécutif quelle que soit son exécutif
qui soit de gauche de centre du centre
en même temps ou de droite
est-ce que l'association deviendrait
trop trop Macron pour exécutif s'il est
élu moi je vous remarquerez que dans mes
prises de position je sais toujours de
rester concentré sur mon projet j'ai
apporté des choses très concrètes
comment on peut soutenir les maires H24
en période de crise comment on peut les
soutenir lorsqu'ils sont agressés
lorsque il y a une catastrophe naturelle
là il y a cette élection a pris une
tournure le politiser à partir du moment
où il y a pas eu de liste unique
contrairement à ce que j'ai proposé
jusqu'au bout et je tiens à le confirmer
ici
vous lui avez proposé
bien sûr évidemment et avec donc une
compétition entre deux équipes des
équipes qui s'inscrivent dans cette
pluralité évidente et les équipes qui
ont de la pluralité mais qui sont
presque à 70% composé de maire qui qui
soutient le président de la République
alors on a le droit de soutien président
de la République moi je souhaite qu'il y
ait des personnes qui le soutiennent
dans avec moi parce que ça fait partie
de la vie politique mais on peut pas
avoir
des maires qui représentent 2,2% des
communes de plus de 10000 habitants on
l'a vu au dernier résultat ou 0,2% de
toutes les communes de France à avoir
70% de la représentativité à la MF mais
vous dites que vous avez voulu faire une
alliance avec Philippe Laurent qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il a refusé
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce pourquoi c'est
un capoter
écoutez je l'ignore il faut demander un
film porno il était
trop
courtes et je souhaite qu'elle le reste
donc je veux pas me laisser embarquer
par par la spirale de l'excitation après
électorale mais jusqu'au bout je voilà
et tout le monde le sait en tout cas
ceux qui suivent ça de près j'ai essayé
de faire en sorte que on propose une
équipe unique comme c'est la tradition à
la MF pour être le pur représentatif
possible des maires de France je crois
que c'est l'enjeu est là
qui est de fataux très politisés vous
avez chacun vos soutiens vos détracteurs
hier
c'est le président de votre région
Renault Muselier qui appelle les maires
de votre région à voter pour Philippe
Laurent il la démo très dur envers vous
il dit il dit au maire de sa région je
vous affirme que le maire de canne du
haut de son tapis rouge niché dans son
palais des festivals ne pourra jamais
comprendre ce que vous et vos
concitoyens vivez au quotidien dans vos
territoires qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à ça franchement parce que quoi que vous
fassiez ça vous tire vers le bas vous
avez cité ce propos qui est violent qui
correspond pas à ma vie voilà je suis
mère en ce qui me concerne c'est pas le
cas de celui qui tient ce propos je vis
dans mon quartier de République je
connais ma vie voilà c'est tout
franchement vous pouvez vous expliquer
ce qui lui prend un Renault Muselier je
crois qu'il est chez certaines de vos
confrères ce matin il expliquera je sais
que en 2014 quand je me suis présenté il
était venu soutenir un autre
candidats contre une contre une promesse
de députée le député européen
pour les Forces Républicaines c'est ce
qui me dit mais c'est tellement absurde
j'ai appelé à voter pour les Forces
Républicaines selon la formule c'est
écrit ça a été dit c'est chez vos
confrères et vraiment je j'essaie de de
garder la dignité parce que parce que
j'ai un peu d'expérience et je sais que
ce type de d'attaque très très grossière
quoi un peu vulgaire vous tire toujours
vers le bas quoi que vous disiez donc
chacun se fera son opinion
qui nous écoutent ce matin ils ont
sûrement envie de savoir est-ce que vous
serez une force d'opposition ou est-ce
que vous serez un partenaire de
l'exécutif dans les dossiers qui
concernent les maires je pense que la MF
elle doit être indépendante et elle doit
être un partenaire loyal de l'État et
pour être loyal il faut être libre et
donc pour être libre par définition il
faut pas être vastalisé ou que la MF
soit une antichambre du pouvoir et à ce
titre c'est la singularité de
l'Association des maires de France et
moi je souhaite que l'AMF soit
évidemment comme elle l'est au quotidien
parce que on parle toujours des points
de divergence et la MF est là pour
défendre les libertés locales elle a été
créée pour ça en 1907 et là pour faire
entendre la voix des mers faire
respecter les mers qui souvent ont été
méprisés mais quand vous regardez les
dernières années évidemment la MF a
juste titre d'ailleurs tout le monde
partageait ses positions y compris ceux
qui aujourd'hui parle d'une dérive
politicienne c'était les premiers à
voter l'émotion et à les revendiquer au
sein de l'exécutif de l'AMF donc qu'on
s'oppose à la nationalisation de la taxe
d'habitation quand s'offusque de ce
hashtag ton maire qui avait été lancé
par l'exécutive qu'on conteste le
dispositif de Cahors qui a encadré
administrativement de dépenses par un
État qui lui est surendettée sur
fiscalisé sur des pensées et sur
taillons c'est normal que la MF prenne
ses positions en revanche quand il y a
le dispositif cœur de ville la MF fait
partenaire et au quotidien on travaille
donc il faut garder cet esprit non
partisan l'AMF ne doit pas être un parti
politique les MF elle doit représenter
toutes les communes et Doudou ça
nécessitait de représentativité et moi
c'est ce que je fais dans ma commune
c'est à dire je suis qui je suis j'ai
mes convictions je ne les cache pas mais
j'ai aucun sectarisme ok et vous savez
je connais des gens qui sont beaucoup
plus ambiguës sur leur conviction
beaucoup plus sinueux et qui sont en
fait très secteur et qui n'acceptent pas
que certaines personnes aient des
conditions moi c'est pas mon cas et vous
vous élu président de la MF quel est
votre première mesure votre priorité la
première heure la première mesure au
delà d'une réorganisation interne que je
ferai avec la belle équipe
administrative qui allait MF il y a
beaucoup de compétences c'est d'essayer
de créer une astreinte H24 pour les cas
d'urgence qu'on rencontre en tant que
maire moi j'en ai on a besoin parfois de
conseils immédiats
ça va sur des situations de
pardonnez-moi de
crise mais aussi ça peut être au
quotidien sur des appels à projets on
est assommé d'appel à projet beaucoup de
mairies n'ont pas l'ingénierie
nécessaire
ça fonctionne c'est pas lourd en
fonctionnement ça fait toujours peur
quand on en parle en interne mais c'est
très léger mais c'est pas le plus
important le plus important c'est aussi
depuis la fin du cumul de mandat
député-maire on voit que la fabrication
des lois est devenue encore un peu plus
si c'était possible technocratique et
hors-sol on l'a vu encore récemment sur
les ânes et sur d'autres dispositions et
donc ce que je proposerai au président
des chambres et
à l'exécutif si bien sûr je suis
président de la MF c'est qu'on crée un
comité exécutif local législatif pour
travailleurs en amont sur tous les
textes qui concernent l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics et essayer de faire
entendre la voix des mères y compris des
maires de la ruralité qui sont souvent
les grands perdants de le texte et je
peux vous citer une somme de mesure qui
sont dans un programme que j'ai de
plusieurs pages que j'ai envoyé par
email à tous les maires de France
des finances vous en avez un petit peu
parlé cette question de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation à laquelle
l'Association des Maires s'oppose
comment vous faites pour revenir dessus
est-ce que ça vous paraît possible de
demander au prochain Président de la
République de revenir dessus et comment
on fait pour compenser la perte qui a
été celle des mères de France avec cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation il y
a une perte qui a été celle de la sur la
DGF jamais été remboursé c'était à
partir de l'été 2014 c'était sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande et la
MF en indépendance y compris avec son
premier vice-président socialiste c'est
opposé à cette mesure on parle de on
parle de 11 milliards en fait il faut
regarder en cumulé budgétaire c'est 22
milliards qui ont été soustrés c'était
de l'argent qui appartenait aux communes
et puis il y a eu effectivement la taxe
d'habitation qui pour l'instant a été
compensé
90% on va dire mais pas à 100% on sait
dans le temps que les compensations de
l'État s'étiolent et qu'on arrive qu'à
40% au bout de 10 ans de compensation
c'est l'histoire qui nous montre ça avec
les départements
donc l'enjeu là-dessus et de je crois
non seulement d'être défensif de
rappeler la nécessité de défendre les
dotations on n'est pas des quémandeurs
on n'est pas des pleurs des chars c'est
un argent qui appartient aux
contribuable locaux qui appartient aux
collectivité que l'État s'approprie mais
au-delà des défensif il faut surtout
être proactif constructif et moi je
souhaite que la MF elle soit
constructive et qu'on propose et je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus
d'ailleurs une puisque c'est des
résolutions qu'on prend depuis trois ans
cette grande loi des libertés locales
que nous as selon tous de nos vœux pour
retrouver le principe de subsidiarité au
coeur de la République et que pour
chaque collectivité il y ait un impôt et
je crois que ça nous permettra aussi de
retrouver du lien civique parce qu'on
parle de la dévitalisation financière
des communes on parle de la
dévitalisation en matière d'urbanisme on
parle de ces contraintes juridiques
administratives mais il faut parler
aussi de la dévitalisation civique qui
est peut-être le problème le plus grave
avec une abstention élevée avec des
citoyens qui sont tentés soit de ne plus
s'occuper de la vie politique et la vie
civique soit d'aller vers les extrêmes
vers les humeurs donc on a un enjeu de
clarté de simplicité d'efficacité dans
l'organisation vous êtes clairement vous
êtes là clairement partisan de recréer
un impôt municipal c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de vous dire un pot
municipal aujourd'hui qui est le foncier
bâti et avec des situations
il faut je crois qu'on a une nécessité
de organiser l'appareil de public pour
sortir de la suadministration
aujourd'hui il faut jamais oublier une
chose c'est que les tâches de back
office administratif en France consomme
35% des effectifs de la fonction
publique la moyenne européenne c'est 24%
de l'Allemagne qui est bien illustré
c'est 25% c'est 8 points c'est 450 000
fonctionnaires qui ne sont pas sur le
terrain il faut qu'on ait plus de
fonctionnaires sur le terrain il faut
qu'on retrouve donc qu'on arrive à
abaisser la pression fiscale mais en
revanche on doit avoir eu un lien entre
l'habitant et le local c'est ce qui crée
de la responsabilité y compris pour les
élus qui rendent des comptes aujourd'hui
en rang de moins en moins de comptes
fiscaux donc ça nous incite pas à
l'efficacité on va parler de la
décentralisation vous ne l'avez dit vous
souhaitez une grande loi de liberté
locale pour le prochain quinquennat vous
avez une expression qui est assez forte
vous parlez d'archaïsme centralisateur
de la part de l'État le l'un des thèmes
l'un des points forts de ce congrès pour
l'AMF c'est la renégociation de la
relation entre l'État et les
collectivités comment ça doit se
traduire concrètement pour vous
complet législatif d'organisation des
des pouvoirs publics on a une colonne
vertébrale entre l'État et les communes
et avec les départements et les régions
et les départements qui ont une forte
identité aussi une forte vocation dans
l'histoire de notre pays et là dessus
alors il faudra que la MF adopte une
position commune pour être forte qui
soit pas la position d'un parti
politique ou du président de la MF qui
devra être la position des maires de
France et valider par les instances
comme métier directeurs et bureaux c'est
ça aussi la force de la ML
la nouvelle dénominateur commun non je
crois d'ailleurs je ne le crois pas je
lisais la lettre du carendida communiste
à la présidentielle Dieu sait que je ne
suis pas communiste et qui a adressé au
maire si vous voulez ça allait être pour
rescueillir les parrainages je vous
invite à la lire je pense que quelqu'un
qui a une fibre comme moi très attachée
aux libertés locales s'y retrouve
complètement donc j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui les c'est plus un clivage
droite-gauche c'est il y a des
étatsistes et puis ceux qui qui savent
que la modernité elle est à la à la
responsabilité et à la liberté et donc y
compris sur le plan local on va parler
de la question de la sécurité oui on a
on a parlé de l'attaque qui a frappé
votre ville en début d'émission la
sécurité des élus et et est en jeu
aujourd'hui on a on disait tout à
l'heure que les agressions des notamment
des élus locaux ont triplé ces dernières
années Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur demande aujourd'hui au
préfet de renforcer la surveillance des
permanences voir des domiciles privées
des élus est-ce que l'État est
suffisamment à vos côtés sur ces
questions
[Musique]
de nos communes s'occupent moins de
notre vie mais s'occupe plus de ce qu'il
regarde c'est à dire la sécurité les
fonctions régaliennes
c'est l'heure du bilan du quinquennat
aussi pour Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État qui sera présent jeudi et qui va
conclure votre congrès qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de ce discours du chef de
l'État et comment vous qualifier ce
qu'un Kenna dans les relations entre les
mers et l'État c'est difficile parce que
je le rappelais tout à l'heure qui a
commencé par
la nationalisation de la taxe
d'habitation c'est c'est un enjeu entre
22 milliards et 25 milliards c'est que
l'on prenne en compte ou pas les
résidences secondaires par le dispositif
de Cahors qui était un truc très
bureaucratique très techno qui voulait
encadrer nos dépenses de fonctionnement
alors que nous n'empruntons que pour
l'investissement comme nous en
entreprise on implique la règle d'or
dans une commune le hashtag balance ton
maire mais et puis au-delà de ça il y
avait une petite musique qui rendait
sans arrêt les mairies les mers et des
ringards les méristes un archaïsme on
était bon que qu'à faire des
ronds-points etc et puis il y a eu les
gilets jaunes et tout a changé on est
passé de balance ton maire accroche-toi
à ton mère
et avec ensuite une somme de discours
parfois de flatterie y compris pendant
la crise covid mais dans la réalité on
voyait bien mais pas que les mères
d'ailleurs tous les Français y compris
les préfets apprenez les mesures à la
télé on nous disait le mardi que les
marchés alimentaires restaient ouverts
et puis on recevait un arrêté
ministériel dans la nuit du vendredi au
samedi ce que je vous dis du vécu à 5h
du matin au moment où les gens avaient
déjà déballé leurs fruits et légumes en
disant il faut vite emballer parce que
les marchés sont interdits donc je crois
qu'il y a une meilleure volonté qui se
traduit par l'action de certains
ministres comme Jacqueline Gouraud comme
Sébastien qui connaissent bien les
communes qui a un discours qui a changé
mais que dans la réalité le le carcan
descendant le carcan bureaucratique est
tellement fort que même lorsque l'on
veut être agréable avec les mères ça se
traduit par des schémas en plus ça
traduit par des appels à projets donc à
chaque fois par des canaux très
verticaux mais du coup s'inscrire les
grandes villes les villes qu'on
l'ingénierie mais dans lesquelles ne
peuvent pas s'inscrire beaucoup de
comment c'est un problème d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est un problème de l'état de
l'État centralien
je crois que le Président de la
République qui est assez défauts et ses
qualités qui a fait des bonnes choses et
des mauvaises choses il faut surtout pas
être maniché dans la vie et la vie nous
a fait un relativiser tout ça mais à une
forme à une formation à une expérience
de vie qui l'éloigne de la de la réalité
quotidienne et du terrain donc qui fait
qu'il a du mal je pense à concevoir ce
que l'on vit au quotidien comment la MF
si vous êtes élu président va
s'impliquer dans dans la présidentielle
est-ce que vous souhaitez que les
candidats viennent devant les maires
d'abord elle l'a pas à prendre parti
évidemment la MF comme je disais tout à
l'heure elle doit être indépendante elle
doit être neutre dans dans son exil dans
son émanation en revanche ce qu'il la
composent font bien ce qu'ils veulent
c'est pas une association de qui se doit
la neutralité des fonctionnaires c'est
une association d'élus voilà en revanche
l'AMF dans ces prises de position
souhaite strictement neutre équitable et
faire ce que nous avions fait d'ailleurs
en 2017 et pourquoi pas moi je
souhaiterais qu'on le fasse avec
territoire uni c'est-à-dire avec région
de France et avec les départements de
France avec il faut travailler la mano
et la mano et que l'on reçoit les
candidats à la fois pour essayer
d'obtenir des engagements en faveur de
notre conception de la solidarité des
libertés locales et dernière question et
vous à titre à titre personnel vous êtes
républicain en fait comment comment qui
soutenez-vous dans le cadre de la
primaire en fait moi je suis candidat à
la présidence d'association du maire de
France serait bien irrespectueux du
maire que et bien stupide de ma part
d'ailleurs que que de prendre position
dans dans ce congrès je veux dire des
gens de qualité qui qui s'affrontent
avec beaucoup de je trouve de courtoisie
et après on n'est pas obligé de partager
les convictions qui sont les autres mais
je trouve avec du respect mutuel du
respect des spectateurs j'ai regardé les
débats on sentait qu'il y avait une
volonté de travailler les dossiers de de
pas être enflammé de et puis voilà les
militants choisiront mais c'est autre
chose moi mon combat mon engagement
c'est la MF c'est c'est le combat de ma
vie merci beaucoup merci à vous d'être
venu sur ce plateau
[Musique]